- Hey, everyone, welcome
to re:Invent 2025.
Thank you for choosing to spend
the next one hour or so with us.
We're gonna make it worthwhile.
In this session, we'll discuss
how you can make your
application data resilient
using Clumio, and these applications
can be Gen AI or otherwise.
We'll go through a host of scenarios
ranging all the way from NoSQL databases
to Rack data pipelines
to data lake houses.
Quick round of introductions.
My name is Akshay Joshi.
I'm a senior director
of product management
here at Clumio, and Clumio is now part
of the Commvault cloud portfolio,
and I'm joined by Jeff.
- Good morning, everyone.
My name is Jeff Cassiana.
I am a principal engineer in
our cloud sales organization
focusing on Clumio and AWS.
I'm also a former Amazonian.
I was a storage specialist
solutions architect.
It's great to be speaking with you today.
- Cool.
All right, so let's get started.
Before we begin, let's take a look at why
we need to care about
resilience right now.
AI is everywhere, and
52% of the data leaders
that were surveyed by AWS said
that their data foundations
are not ready for AI implementation,
and that's horrible.
And that's why we're here
to talk about resilience
at the data layer.
It's absolutely foundational.
Oh.
- We wanna acknowledge something
right off the bat, though.
Resiliency can mean a
lot of different things,
but I think we can all agree
it's essential to your
cloud infrastructure.
Akshay and I speak to
customers all the time.
We speak to companies, and
we get many definitions
of what resiliency is,
but one thing's consistent
is that there are common occurrences
that affect resiliency in the cloud
in a pretty negative way,
and we've put a few of those
as examples on the screen.
The first being an accidental deletion.
This can be somebody just
accidentally making a mistake
and deleting a directory in
your cloud infrastructure
that has some critical data on it.
It could be a cleanup script
that perhaps wasn't just fully dialed in.
It's basically a mistake,
and mistakes occur.
Humans are mistake-prone.
They're not perfect, that can happen.
That's definitely one reason
why resiliency is essential.
Another is something that
we probably have all heard
in the news lately where
code pushes maybe go wrong,
and it becomes a front page
of the internet type event.
Software is not perfect.
It can create havoc.
It can create a scenario
where resiliency does suffer,
and lastly, it's almost
a hour-by-hour thing.
It's definitely a day-by-day thing
where bad actors act with negative intent
on your cloud infrastructure.
Prime example is ransomware,
but that's not the only example,
so we wanna establish what
we believe resiliency to be
and why it is absolutely essential
in your cloud infrastructure.
Let's get some participation
from the audience
if you don't mind.
We have a couple questions
that we would like to see
you raise your hands in response to.
The first is how many of you
are using the AWS Cloud today
to build your applications?
I already got one hand.
To build your applications
in a generative AI way
with a generative AI or a
large language model pipeline,
I see a bunch of raised hands.
That's great.
Like I mentioned, Akshay and
I speak to a lot of companies
very frequently, and this is
extremely common these days
in the AWS Cloud.
AWS is very effective at
making that a reality.
One second question that I would love
to get a raise of hands about as well,
similar and related to
the previous question,
how many of you are actually
protecting the data layer
that powers these gen
AI cloud applications?
Is that something you
take seriously today,
or is it an overlooked factor?
Less hands.
That's actually very common.
It's very related to what Akshay
and I hear from companies.
They're really building
some incredible stuff
in the AWS Cloud that
powers their chat bots,
but it's interesting how often
data protection is overlooked.
We're gonna paint a real-world
picture for you today.
We created a fictitious app.
I wanna emphasize this is not real.
We didn't get permission to
use any actual real apps.
There's actually a
little bit of humor here,
lightheartedness.
It was vibe coded by our
CTO in about a weekend.
It's really kind of cool.
I'm very impressed by it.
It's called Clumio Final Cut.
Think of it as an app, a smartphone app
that similar to probably
what you use today.
It's using an openly available data set
of thousands of movies,
actual real movies,
that typically is used
for machine learning type experimentation.
And here's the picture we wanna paint.
We'll call this user Sharon here.
Let's go ahead and press play.
We have a video going here.
This is our user Sharon.
She's using the Clumio Flick app.
She's loving it, but all of
a sudden, something happens.
Resiliency is suffering.
She tries to go use the AI
chatbot as a part of the app
to provide her with recommendations
of what she wants to watch
next, and it starts to fail.
There's her using the
movie assistant chatbot
as a part of the app that we built.
And you can see errors
are starting to pop up.
It failed to load.
She has a watch list.
It's not finding her entries.
She's frustrated.
She went from happy to unhappy.
Like a typical smartphone user
who have come to expect extremely
good performance from AWS
because AWS has set the
bar very high with that,
she goes to her favorite social media app
and starts complaining.
Perhaps her friends see her complaints,
the people she follows, they
start noticing the failures.
This is a bad day.
This is a failure of
the cloud application.
Let's dissect what's going on here.
And in order to do that,
I'm gonna pass it back over to Akshay
to explain the first
part of the cloud app.
- Thank you, Jeff.
All right, we all saw Sharon
struggle with the application.
Now let's see how we can
dissect the application
and see what's happening under the hood.
So let's go feature by feature.
The first feature that
Sharon struggled with
was the user profile data
and the watch list data.
And the application uses
DynamoDB under the hood
to store user profile data
and the watch list data.
And DynamoDB is actually a perfect choice
to store that kind of data
because it's inherently partitioned
and it's multi-tenant in nature.
And finally, it's also highly scalable.
Now, a couple of our customers
actually use DynamoDB
for the very same reasons,
to store user data.
While scalable, it's also
absolutely vulnerable.
So imagine a standard canary deployment
where you're updating your
application in tranches.
Users get the updates in tranches.
And if a code push goes wrong,
this may be due to a bug, for example,
the users won't be able
to access the data at all
because those partitions
would get corrupted.
And that's what happened
to Sharon in our example.
She couldn't use her user
profile or watch list screens
because the underlying
DynamoDB table got impacted.
Now, let's visualize
the problem a bit more.
Let's see how the event unfolded.
As I mentioned, the canary
deployment starts at 1 p.m. here
and then partitions are
being updated in tranches.
And at 2.30 p.m., somebody reports a bug
that your DynamoDB partitions
have been corrupted.
Thankfully though, in this example,
only a couple of partitions were impacted
but then there could be a scenario
where thousands of DynamoDB
partitions may get impacted
because it's highly scalable
and consumer apps usually
have millions of users.
So the complication here is
that every single partition
gets impacted at a different timestamp.
So the last known good
copy of a DynamoDB table
is actually not a single timestamp.
It depends on the
partition that's impacted.
And that's the complication
that we're gonna explore
and learn about how to
recover from in this session.
All right, so in case of such an event,
let's wear the hat of an SRE.
SRE has four recovery imperatives
to deal with at that point.
First, they'll have to recover
to a known good point in time.
And the challenge, as we all know,
is that every single partition
can have a different last good known copy.
And then number two,
you need to also ensure
that the reconfiguration
at the application level
is as little as possible.
Because you don't have to deal
with reconfiguring the application
to talk to a different DynamoDB instance.
And that can be a
time-consuming operation.
Number three, of course, TCL.
You need to ensure that the resources
that you end up spending to
get the app back up online
is as minimal as possible.
And finally, you need to ensure
the best user experience,
which means little to no downtime.
And we don't want Sharon to get frustrated
and go on social media at that point.
So let's take a look
at how you can recover
from such an event.
I'm gonna talk about two different ways
of recovering from any event.
One, the hard way, and
two, the simple way,
which is the Clumio way.
So in the absence of Clumio,
it's an arduous process.
For each partition's last
known good point in time,
you have to do a full restore.
And mind you, this is for
each and every partition
that's impacted, you'll
have to do a full restore.
And then you need to
cherry-pick the pieces
for each partition from the full restores,
copy it back to the source table
so that you don't have to
reconfigure the application
at a later point in time.
And finally, delete all
the temporary tables
that you've created.
And finally, I want to mention
that you have to do this
over and over again for
every single partition
that's impacted.
If you have 1,000 partitions impacted,
you'll have to do this 1,000 times.
Now imagine that.
That's recovery hell.
And now, let's take a
look at how simple it is
to recover using Clumio
Backtrack for DynamoDB.
It's literally a two-step process.
Step number one, you pick a point in time,
choose a partition that you wanna recover,
hit recover, and that's about it.
It recovers only what's needed
for every single partition
to the point in time that you've selected
and directly to the source table
so you don't have to reconfigure
the application at all.
And step number two, there is no step two.
Simple as that, all right?
So let's learn a bit more
about Clumio Backtrack for DynamoDB.
We launched Clumio Backtrack for DynamoDB
back in June of this year.
It's essentially a recovery modality
with three distinct features.
One, you can recover to any point in time
that's available in your backup.
Two, it's in-place restore.
It means that it goes back
to the source table directly
so that you don't have to
create temporary tables,
repoint the application to
talk to a different restored
DynamoDB table or none of that.
And then three, granular recovery.
You can perform a recovery
at any granularity
and this can be, in the case of DynamoDB,
it can be at the record
level, partition level,
or at the table level itself.
Now let's see the feature
and the event in action.
I'm gonna hand it back to Jeff
to show you a quick demo on that.
- Thank you, Akshay.
We prerecorded a demo of our vibecoded app
called Clumio Flick and what
I'm gonna demonstrate today
is what Akshay just explained
about what Clumio Backtrack
for DynamoDB is capable of doing.
What you see on the screen right here
is what we call the movie watch list.
But this particular part
of the app is a watch list
that allows you to search
for a particular customer's watch list
and it is all entirely based on DynamoDB.
You can see I've highlighted the section
that all of these records are
coming from DynamoDB items.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
search for Customer ID 3.
That takes me to Customer
ID 3's specific watch page,
so very similar to what
you might experience
in your favorite movie smartphone app.
In that customer watch list,
I have two things that I can do.
I can use the AI Movie
Assistant as a chatbot
to interact with our large
language model pipeline
and ask questions using
natural language prompts.
In this case, I'm gonna ask,
"Tell me more about the
movie Clumio to the Moon."
I mentioned we're using real movies
in this openly available dataset,
but we did insert one just
for a little bit of humor
that is related to a fictitious
movie that Clumio created.
And then in the watch list,
it's actually mentioned in there.
And then I'm gonna show
you in the AWS console
where all of this is coming from.
We have a DynamoDB table
that has all of the user
watch lists in there.
I'm gonna filter the table by
just the Customer ID 3 items,
and you can see the corresponding items
in that DynamoDB table.
This is the critical data to
ensure a good user experience
is resilient for Customer ID 3.
You can see in the Movie
AI Assistant chatbot,
it has responded with
some really interesting,
rich information about Clumio to the Moon.
Things like the plot of the movie,
some interesting metadata about revenue,
even some catchphrases
when the movie was created,
and the genre as well.
This is a happy state.
This is Sharon loving the
app, having a great time,
a user that will come back,
a user that will be loyal to you.
Let's simulate an unhappy situation.
Let's simulate a bad day,
a bad user experience.
We're gonna do that with a
Python script that we created
that will purposely,
let's simulate corruption
in Customer ID's DynamoDB items.
Essentially, we're removing them,
simulating perhaps an
accidental deletion scenario
like I mentioned a second ago.
I refreshed the User ID's,
Customer ID 3's watch list page.
Everything's gone.
This is absolutely a
demonstration of what we showed
that Sharon experienced a second ago.
There's nothing there.
Unhappy customer, unhappy user.
I'm gonna refresh the DynamoDB table.
That simulated corruption
has completely removed
Customer ID's entries
and there's no matches found now
when I filter for that
particular customer.
The good news is we are
taking a backup of this table
and we have been for some time.
What you're seeing on the screen
is the Clumio SaaS interface.
Our calendar view,
everywhere you see a dot
in that calendar view is a point in time
we can recover back to.
Usually, like Akshay was mentioning,
this is a very difficult
process to restore.
Resiliency and faith in
your customer with Clumio.
All I need to do, and I
have different options here,
is choose a recovery modality.
The first one I'm gonna show you
is our cyber resilient recovery modality.
So unlike the simulation we're creating
where there's been accidental deletion,
that's ideal for if there is
a compromise of some kind,
a cyber related threat.
You're recovering the DynamoDB table
or individual Customer ID's item
from an air-gapped immutable secure copy
that will be unaffected in the event
of a cyber related incident.
I have multiple different points in time
in just that particular
day in the calendar.
So I have a lot of choices here.
But what I wanna demonstrate
is going back to a point in time in place.
Something that we announced,
like Akshay mentioned a couple months ago,
with Clumio Backtrack for DynamoDB.
What you can see on the screen
is I picked a point in time.
I know the text is a little small,
but I did pick a point in time
where I know that there is
a good DynamoDB recovery
point to go back to,
and I'm given three options.
The one I'm highlighting
is the in place option.
That is the Clumio Backtrack for DynamoDB.
That is avoiding all of
the app reconfiguration
that Akshay mentioned just a second ago,
and recovering Customer
ID's specific item entries
alone in place.
All I need to do is search for
the Customer ID string three,
which I'll do at the bottom here.
When I press Preview, it'll
query that point in time
to make sure that what I wanna recover
is actually correct in there.
I've successfully found
the recovery items.
I'm given a summary of
what I'm about to do,
just to confirm that I'm
doing the right thing.
I'm gonna initiate the restore
that has created a
brand new task in Clumio
that I can monitor for completeness.
The very beginning of the task,
it is queued, and through
the magic of video editing,
we're just going to skip ahead
to when the actual task has completed.
And in order to prove that
it has been completed,
and this is a very similar
scenario to what you might do,
I'm just gonna refresh the DynamoDB table.
All of the entries have recovered,
and they're back to where they should be.
And just like what a user would experience
like our user Sharon, close
the app in my smartphone,
reopen it, it refreshes the
page, all of my movies are back.
We have successfully restored
resiliency in our application
because of a DynamoDB issue.
We're gonna give you another scenario.
This has to do with S3 specifically.
For that, I'll pass it
back over to Akshay.
- All right, thank you, Jeff.
That was a great demo.
The second feature that
we're gonna talk about today
is the concierge chat bot.
You would have seen Sharon
interacting with the chat bot
where she's asking
recommendations about movies,
and then more details about
the movies that she watched.
So that's the chat bot using,
I mean, that's built using
a large language model.
And again, this is a typical LLM feature
with a rack data pipeline
that we're all familiar with.
It has three components.
One is it has a bunch of
objects with movie details.
These could be like text
files, PDFs, or JSON files,
all of that storing
movie-related information.
And it's stored in an S3 bucket.
And then there is a vector store
where we've computed all
the vector embeddings
from the S3 bucket data,
and we've stored it in S3
vectors for this example.
And then finally, the LLM layer
connects to the vectorized database.
And that is what enables the
LLM to answer the questions
that you ask about any movie
that's available on the app.
Now, again, if the S3 data itself is lost,
then it's gonna be,
basically, the vectors
would be pointing nowhere.
So in that case, the Final Cut chat bot
won't be able to talk to the vector store
because the vectors themselves
are pointing nowhere.
And then finally, Sharon won't
be able to get the answers
that she needs from the
large language model.
So now, let's see how the event unfolded
here, you can see that
as the objects are lost,
the LLM starts going rogue.
You can see that the LLM is not being,
not answering the
questions satisfactorily.
We all know that "Love Actually"
is not an action movie.
So the LLM has basically gone rogue,
and the vector store
is essentially useless
if the bucket data that it's
pointing to is not available.
Now, let's take a look at
the recovery imperatives
once again.
I mean, coming back to the SRE persona
that we keep talking about.
So there are a few changes,
it's again the four recovery imperatives
that the SREs deal with in this scenario,
but then there are a few changes.
First one is that there should be
as little data loss as possible
because the vector data is
pointing to the S3 bucket data,
even if there's a small
amount of data loss
at the S3 bucket level,
then the vectors would
essentially be useless.
So we don't want that situation.
So the first imperative is that
the last known good recovery point
should have all the data and
should have zero data loss.
Number two, there should be
as little reconfiguration
required at the LLM layer as possible.
Again, it's a complex
process to rewire the LLM
to the new vector data store.
So that's why you need to
avoid this as much as possible.
And number three, you need
to keep your costs in check.
Recomputing the vectors
on all of your data
is a time compute and
cost intensive operation.
You wouldn't want to
undertake that kind of effort.
And then finally, user
experience matters once again.
There should be little to no downtime
for users like Sharon.
She shouldn't get frustrated
asking simple questions as,
hey, is "Love Actually" a
comedy movie or an action movie?
So now again, I'm gonna show you
what recovery hell looks like.
And then we'll talk about Clumio.
In the absence of Clumio, again,
what you have to do is you
have to do a full restore
of the S3 bucket back to
a last known good copy.
And then you need to recompute the vectors
on the restored bucket.
And you need to remove
the old vector store.
You need to clean up all of that data.
And then you need to clean
up the old bucket as well.
And then finally, you
need to point your LLM
to the new vector store
because your vector store
itself has changed now.
Your S3 bucket was restored
to a completely different
bucket than it was.
So the vector embeddings had
to be recomputed at that point.
And the S3 vector store
would also be a different
bucket altogether.
Now the LLM has to be pointed to that.
Now again, let's go back to Clumio
and take a look at Clumio's
two-step recovery process.
So this is possible due to
Clumio backtrack for S3.
We'll talk about Clumio
backtrack for S3 in just a bit.
But again, step number one,
you select a point in time,
choose only the impacted objects.
Mind you, you don't need to
restore the entire bucket here.
It's not all or nothing with us.
You restore only the impacted pieces.
You choose the impacted
objects and then click restore.
And step number two, there is no step two.
No need to recompute
the vectors, no cleanup,
no changes at the LLM
layer, simple as that.
All right, so we launched Clumio backtrack
for Amazon S3 last year
at re:Invent, in fact.
And backtrack for S3 is basically
the three same features packaged together.
It's in-place recovery
so that you can recover
back to the source bucket itself
without having to reconfigure
the application layer,
vector store, or LLM, none of that.
And granular recovery,
again, in case of S3,
granularity can mean different things.
So in S3, granularity can
be at the object level,
prefix level, or at the
bucket level itself.
And finally, point in time recovery.
You can go back to any point in time
that's available in our
backup using Clumio backtrack.
And note that Clumio backtrack for S3
works with or without SecureVault.
SecureVault is our backup offering.
Again, you may be using versioning for S3,
and that may be your
idea of data protection,
and we don't judge you for that.
That's totally fine.
You can still roll back your versions
to any given point in time using backtrack
without the need to back it up with us.
And finally, we have
continuous change tracking
for S3 objects, which means
that every single change
that happens at the object
level or at the version level
is continuously tracked,
and we back it up.
So that there is absolutely
no data loss whatsoever.
If you remember, this ties back
to the very first recovery imperative
that the SREs deal with.
All right, so now let's
see this in action.
I'm gonna hand it off to
Jeff for a quick demo.
There you go.
- Great stuff, Akshay.
So I wanna acknowledge, again,
resiliency is important,
but also what we've experienced
and what Akshay just explained is accuracy
in your chatbot is also
extremely important.
It's very common and
actually really, really easy
for LLMs to spit out
gibberish, to hallucinate,
to give inaccurate information.
That doesn't necessarily,
that can happen very easily
by just having some sort
of incident or event
that has data loss associated with it.
So let's go back to our
ClumioFlix vibe-coded app
in the AWS cloud.
We're now back at customer ID three,
just like we were before.
And I'm gonna give it another prompt.
I'm gonna ask it to tell me
more about Clumio to the,
I'm sorry, yeah, I'm gonna
ask it to tell me more
about Clumio to the moon,
just like we did before
in the DynamoDB example.
While we wait for that
to think, I'll go ahead
and highlight that we have
an entire part of the app,
just like what Sharon was experiencing,
that is dedicated to
just a specific movie.
And in this case, we're highlighting
our lighthearted Clumio to the moon movie.
You can see there's a lot of rich, cool,
interesting information
about that particular movie.
I can totally imagine a business
wanting to do research
on a particular movie.
This could be really helpful for them.
Information like the plot,
the revenue that it generated,
movies that are similar to it.
This could be very helpful for researching
the next project, for example.
You may have noticed
that in the address bar,
and this would be the same
thing with a smartphone app,
that that movie was
represented by a number.
This entire openly
available movie database
is filled with S3 object
files in JSON format
that are represented by a number.
You can see that on the screen.
I'm highlighting the actual S3 bucket
that we're using for this
app called Clumio Demo Movie.
Each one of the objects is
a number followed by .json.
Just to show you this specific object
for Clumio to the moon, I'll
do a search for 7000.json.
That's what's connected and associated
with Clumio to the moon,
and highlight that we do
have S3 versioning enabled.
Like Akshay said, it's a great choice.
Doesn't necessarily
provide 100% resiliency,
but it's very fantastic that
AWS offers something like that.
What Clumio has done
is enhanced the ability
to leverage it at scale.
I also point out that
we're also using S3 tables
for providing this information,
and then S3 vectors as well.
And again, like the
DynamoDB, the good news is
we're backing this S3 bucket with Clumio,
and we have multiple
different recovery points
that we can go back to in the last month.
Just like with the DynamoDB recording
we showed you a second ago,
lots of cool, interesting information
in response to the natural language prompt
that we put into the chat
bot about Clumio to the moon.
Sharon's happy, it's a good day.
Everything's good, no recovery is needed.
Let's turn that around.
Let's let resilience
suffer in a simulated way
by executing another Python script
that will harm that S3 object.
It'll essentially remove it.
To prove that that actually occurred,
and we're now in a bad day scenario,
I'll go ahead and submit the exact
same prompt I gave before,
or I'm asking the chat bot
to give me more information
about Clumio to the moon.
While we wait for that to think,
I'll refresh the actual page
which would be representative
of where you would go
in the app to find it.
The movie is gone.
In that, so now we're creating a scenario
like we did in the video with
Sharon where she's frustrated,
she's going to social
media and complaining.
I'll refresh my S3 bucket.
The 7000.json file, completely gone.
There's no matches found.
And that response that I'm now getting
from the exact same
natural language prompt
to the AI movie assistant is different.
It's inaccurate, it's shorter,
it's not as interesting, not as helpful.
It even says at the bottom,
unfortunately, I don't
have all the information.
Like Akshay said, the pipeline's broken.
It's now no longer able to access
that rich, interesting information
from the .json object in that S3 bucket.
Let's do like what we did with DynamoDB.
Let's use Clumio Backtrack for S3
to bring the resiliency back.
But again, just like with DynamoDB,
we also have a modality for S3
to recover from Secure Vault.
Like Akshay mentioned, that's
our immutable air-gapped copy.
So if instead we were simulating
a cyber-related event,
this is what I would recommend
to my customers and companies
is to recover from that
immutable air-gapped
cyber-resilient copy of the object.
In order to do that, I just need to search
for the 7000.json in my example.
I don't have to do
that, but in my example,
I just need that object.
It's querying a backup
from the point in time
that I selected.
It found the 7000.json object.
I now have the option to
recover just the latest version
or all versions.
Remember this object in this
bucket has versioning enabled.
There's a lot of benefits
to being able to do that
from a cost and ease point of view.
And like the DynamoDB examples,
I'm given a lot of really
advanced selection options
because I may wanna
customize this restoration.
I can absolutely see a scenario,
especially in a cyber-related event
where I don't wanna recover
to the same AWS account.
If the object in that AWS
account had been compromised,
it's very likely that other
parts of that AWS account
are also compromised.
We give you the ability to recover
to a completely different AWS account,
maybe even one that
you've created brand new
and that is completely clean.
We also give you other options
like recovering to another region.
Maybe there's a
large-scale event occurring
and you need to go to a different region.
And we even give you the ability
to add tags to the object
or store it in a prefix, an S3 prefix.
Very advanced selection options
to make sure that your
particular needs are met
for the specific and
particular recovery scenario
that you have.
But instead, what I wanna demonstrate
is what Akshay mentioned
in what we announced at
AWS re:Invent last year
and that's S3 backtrack for S3.
I'm given the bucket name.
I'm given the point in time.
I'm choosing the point in time.
I apologize, my mistake.
I'm just gonna go ahead
and choose to pick a hour
that's earlier in the same day.
I'm gonna filter what I
see by the 7000.json object
when I press Preview.
It's going to query the S3 versions
at that particular point in time.
It found the 7000.json for
that specific point in time.
Just like I showed you before,
lots of interesting selectivity options
to customize and be very
specific to your recovery needs.
In my example, I'm just
gonna override the source.
I'm gonna override the
most current object.
I've started a new task
in Clumio to get that done
through the magic of video editing.
We're gonna fast forward
to when it's completed.
And to prove that it's been
completed successfully,
I'll go back to the AI Movie Assistant,
provide the exact same
natural language prompt
to tell me more about Clumio to the Moon.
While it's thinking, we'll go ahead
and go back to the movie
page for Clumio to the Moon.
Just like I would if I was
to close and open the app,
I'm refreshing it. It's there.
The data is there.
I'll refresh the S3 bucket.
The 7000.json has returned.
I'll go back to my AI Movie Assistant,
and I'm back to a happy day.
Sharon's happy.
She's getting the exact
same consistent response
with the rich metadata and
rich interesting information
about Clumio to the Moon movie.
We've successfully restored resiliency
in our cloud application.
We have one more scenario
to cover with you today.
This is specific, and I'm
actually very, very excited
about this one, to Apache Iceberg
and our new support for that.
For that, I'll turn it
back over to Akshay.
- Thank you, Jeff.
Another great demo.
The third and the final feature
that we're gonna talk about today
is the Box Office Analyzer.
Again, this is a feature that allows you
to compare movie budgets
and the revenue performance.
This can actually be interesting
for any Hollywood exec out there.
The data layer for this feature
is basically a data lake house
that's powered by Apache Iceberg.
Iceberg has gotten
really popular over time,
and it's the most
preferred open table format
for data lake houses.
And for this specific use case,
we are using S3 tables to
store the Apache Iceberg data.
And not only is this available
as an external feature
for users like Sharon,
but also internal employees of the company
can also use the same data set
to create dashboards internally
to analyze the movie
financial performance.
Iceberg data is actually
vulnerable to writes.
We all know this.
Whenever you run an overwrite query
that changes the schema or
drops a column, for example,
your visualizations don't
really match the schema.
And that mismatch causes
all of your visualizations
to go empty.
And in this case, what has happened
is all of the data in the table,
all of the genres for the movies
are overwritten to comedy.
And that's what we're
gonna talk about here.
And because of that,
Final Cut is not able to
pull the information satisfactorily
and give accurate responses
on the visualizations.
And this would also impact any dashboards
that have been created
internally by the employees
outside of the application.
So we'll fix both of those
issues in this scenario.
Okay, let's take a look at the event.
Let's see what unfolded
that led to the situation.
We are using Athena query here
to pull the data from S3 tables.
And we are using QuickSight
as our dashboarding tool
for this example.
And as you notice here,
as the iceberg tables
are getting impacted,
the dashboarding tool is
malfunctioning as well.
So the dashboards are
showing wrong information,
which should not be the case.
And let's talk about
the hard way to recover
from such a scenario.
But before that, let's take a look
at some of the recovery
imperatives once again.
We see a constant theme here
with the SREs dealing with
the same recovery imperatives
over and over again.
But there are a few things
that you need to keep in mind here.
With iceberg data, the
known good recovery points
are actually snapshots or point in time.
It cannot be a single source of truth.
I mean, you can have the data admin
who's well-versed with iceberg snapshots,
and they may know the snapshot ID.
And the S3 admin, for example,
may know the point in time
where the data was clean.
So it could be either or.
So you need to be mindful
of both of those situations
and deal with that.
And number two, there
should be absolutely no need
to recreate dashboards
or reconfigure the application whatsoever.
So all of the recovery
should happen in place.
And finally, of course,
we know that PCO and timer
absolutely essential to keep in mind.
And with that, let's take
a look at recovery hell.
It's a long process.
If you're backing up only the S3 data,
that's powering the iceberg tables.
So in this case, let's
assume that you're backing up
only the general purpose S3
bucket data under the hood
because there is no other iceberg-aware
data protection offering out
there in the market today.
So you have to back up only the S3 data
that's available to you.
And first, you need to do a full restore
of every single S3 bucket
that's holding the iceberg data.
And then you need to restore
the iceberg table structure
once the full restore completes.
This would mean you have to
reconfigure the manifest files,
metadata files, and the
data files to preserve
or bring back the iceberg table structure.
And you need to point the
application to the new tables
once you've restored it.
And then finally,
reconfigure the application
to talk to this new table
that you've restored.
And finally, you need to
reconfigure the application
and recreate all the dashboards
that you would have created
with the previous dataset.
And that's what recovery hell looks like.
Again, let's take a look at
the two-step recovery process
with Clumio.
Again, Clumio is the
only offering out there
that provides iceberg-aware
data protection.
And with that, step number
one is the backup is absolute.
Backup and restores are
iceberg-aware in nature,
which means that you don't
need to restructure the table
once the data has been recovered.
So you just pick a snapshot,
you pick a point in time,
and then you click on Recover.
And this recovery happens in place,
so you don't need to deal with
any sort of upstream impact.
And step number two, there is no step two,
as with all of our other
recovery modalities
that we covered.
The application doesn't
need to be reconfigured,
the dashboards don't need to be recreated,
and none of that.
It's simple recovery, just a single step.
Now I can say that it's not
a two-step recovery anymore,
it's just one-step recovery.
All right, so we launched
the industry's first
iceberg-aware data protection
offering back in September.
Let's learn a bit more about that.
The iceberg table structure is preserved
both during backup as well as recovery,
so that you don't have
to restructure the table
once the table has been recovered.
Or you don't have to do
anything under the hood
to preserve the table
structure, even during backup.
And you can back it up and restore it,
and recover it without any hassles,
and in a very transactionally
consistent way.
And the data itself is stored outside
of your enterprise security sphere,
as with all of our other
secure world offerings,
which means that your
data is safe, air-gapped,
and immutable, and it can
actually help you recover
from any sort of threat vectors
that we talked about
earlier in the session.
And then finally, you can retain
as many snapshots as possible
with Clumio Secure Vault,
and this is especially useful
if you need to be compliant
with compliance standards
like FINRA or HIPAA
that require you to store
every single transaction
for about seven to eight years.
And finally, another thing that you can do
with Clumio Secure
Vault for Apache Iceberg
is that you can modernize
your iceberg footprint on AWS.
You can actively migrate your tables
from a general-purpose S3 bucket
to the newly-launched
Amazon S3 Tables feature.
All right, so enough about the feature.
Now let's see it in action.
I'm gonna hand it off to
Jeff for one last demo.
- Thank you, Akshay.
Like I mentioned before
Akshay started speaking,
I'm very excited about this.
You heard it correctly from Akshay.
Clumio is the first
Iceberg and S3 Tables-aware
data protection solution in the AWS cloud.
As many of you probably know,
Iceberg is extremely popular
when combined with S3
and various different data pipelines.
It's so popular AWS themselves came out
with a new bucket type, S3 Tables,
at this time last year
at AWS re:Invent 2024.
So we're very happy to be helpful
in being able to participate
in increasing the resiliency
of those different services.
Let me show you another demo.
This is our last demo.
And what you're seeing on the screen
is what we call the movie insights page.
So think of this as, you
know, sharing, using the app
and going to a different part of the app,
again, to probably do some research.
But I can also imagine businesses
using something like this
to do research on maybe what
movie they wanna make next.
They wanna find out that out
of the several thousand movies
that are in our openly available data set,
which ones were the most successful?
Which ones made the most money?
Maybe which ones had the worst returns?
And then we can turn on investment.
Like Akshay said, in the app,
we built this with a pipeline
that included QuickSight
to show this chart
information in a visual way.
I wanna highlight this
chart at the bottom,
revenue by genre.
That's what we're gonna
demonstrate as failing today.
And as you can imagine,
that's some really cool data
that you wanna keep
resilient to keep your users
and maybe even the business users
of your applications happy.
It's broken out by dollar per genre.
And you can see that it's very diverse.
There's a lot of genres listed there.
I'll go ahead and highlight
that we do have an S3 table powering this.
And that S3 table is in
the Apache Iceberg format.
I have it highlighted
here in the AWS console.
And just like with S3 and DynamoDB,
we're also taking
backups of this S3 table.
And we have been for some time now.
We have multiple different
places and points in time
to go back to should we need to.
It's a good day. It's a good thing.
Let's go back to our AI
Movie Assistant chat bot.
But this time I'm gonna give a prompt
to have it tell me the specific genre
for Clumio to the Rune.
I no longer need to know the
information about the movie.
I just wanna know what genre it is.
While it's thinking,
we'll go ahead and explain
how this is querying
that pipeline that Akshay mentioned
and explained a second ago.
It has successfully responded
with the correct genre.
It is action and adventure.
That is the genre of Clumio to the Moon.
Again, another scenario
where sharing is happy
or your business users
are happy of your app.
Let's make it a not so good day.
Let's make it a day where
something bad happens.
Resiliency has suffered.
We need to go back to these imperatives
that Akshay keeps mentioning
to ensure that we increase resiliency
or return back to a
resilient point in time
for this application.
I'm gonna simulate that with
our Python script again,
but this time instead of
actually destroying data,
I'm gonna change the data.
I'm gonna change all the
genres in our S3 table
to be comedy.
When I go back to the movies insight page
and I refresh that, instead
of the data being gone,
the data is incorrect.
I'll go back down to that
chart from QuickSight
that showed the revenue by genre.
Now all 400 billion plus
dollars in revenue is comedy
and all the top movies of revenue
are in the genre of comedy.
This is obviously not correct.
This is bad information.
This is creating a
negative user experience.
Like let's make it worse.
Let's do a second suffering
of the application
by going back and doing what
we did in the previous video
and completely deleting
the 7000.json object again.
I'll go ahead and simulate
the negative experience
that your customers or your businesses
might have in this app
by giving the exact same
natural language prompt
to show me the genre of
"Clumio to the Moon."
And in this case, after
it's done thinking,
it'll respond with incorrect information
and now thinks that "Clumio to
the Moon" is a comedy movie.
We all know that that's not true.
We've looked at the data for that movie
very regularly in these demos.
So recovery needs to be performed.
Resiliency has suffered.
Again, like before,
I have multiple different
recovery modalities.
The first one I'm gonna show
you is again that SecureVault,
immutable air-gapped
cyber-resilient copy of the data.
But in this case, a nice
little added benefit,
Akshay touched on it a second ago.
Not only can we recover from
an immutable air-gapped copy,
but we can also convert the catalog type
from AWS Glue catalog type
to S3 Tables catalog type.
A nice little added, almost
migration-related benefit
to the functionality that Clumio provides
with the resiliency that
we're showing you today.
But for my demonstration instead,
I'm gonna go back to a
very specific point in time
using the built-in native
Apache Iceberg snapshotting.
I'm gonna go back to October.
I'm gonna pick October 30th,
just 'cause I know
that's the point in time
I wanna go back to.
It's successfully found a
snapshot from that point in time.
Again, just like before,
I can even give the option
to convert from an AWS Glue catalog type
to an S3 Table catalog
type during this recovery.
I've executed the restore.
A new task has begun.
But remember, I have multiple things
I need to recover from in this example,
not just one like the previous examples.
I need to go back to
Clumio Backtrack for S3
and do what I did in the previous video
where I recover back to a previous version
of the 7000.json object.
Just like before, I pick a point in time.
I do a filter for the 7000.json object.
It's going to query the
versions for that bucket.
If there's one that exists,
it'll come back with a result showing
that there is a point in time
for that particular object
that I can go back to.
It successfully found it.
Again, I have additional options,
but in this case, I'm just gonna override
the existing object.
Execute the restore task.
Now I have two restore tasks
running simultaneously.
Through the magic of video editing again,
we're gonna fast forward
to when those tasks
have been completed.
I'll go back to that Movies Insights page,
refresh it, which would
be just like a user
or a business closing
the app in my smartphone
and reopening it.
Go back to that same chart
for revenue by genre.
Everything's back to normal.
I've successfully restored
the resiliency for my app
from, in this case, a
multiple failure scenario.
Again, just like before,
ask the AI Movie Assistant
the same prompt I asked before.
I want it to tell me the genre
for "Clumio to the Moon."
As long as everything
was restored correctly
and successfully, it should respond
with the correct and accurate information,
no longer providing a
negative user experience
for Sharon or for the
business, and it has.
It's now showing "Clumio to
the Moon" back to what it was,
which was an action-adventure genre movie.
We're in a happy place.
Sharon's a happy user.
Your businesses, your
customers are happy users.
We're in a good spot.
Let's look at Sharon again,
our trusty user for our smartphone app.
She's now looking at it again.
After we've done our restorations,
her expectations are high,
which she should have high expectations
because AWS has set the bar so
high for this type of stuff.
She does the same search.
She found a great movie
she wants to watch,
and she started watching
it, eating her popcorn
with a smile on her face.
We're back to a resilient
state for our smartphone app,
our cloud-based app.
Now that we've gone through
all of these scenarios
and we've explained to
you how Clumio can help
increase your resiliency and
why it's important to do so
in the cloud using these
Gen AI pipeline-based,
cloud-based apps, we
wanna leave you with a,
and summarize a few pieces of
recommendations that we have.
The first is what we
think are requirements
for when you design your data strategies,
data backup and protection strategies,
and maximize your
potential for resilience.
Eliminate the risk of
those three examples I gave
at the beginning of the presentation.
I'll start with the first one.
You need to protect your
entire data pipeline.
The Clumio Flick app, what
Sharon was using, was simple.
Like I said, our CTO vibe
coded it in a weekend.
Most likely you have
applications running in the cloud
that are more complex,
that are multifaceted,
that have detailed pipelines that involve
maybe a dozen or a dozen
more services in AWS.
It's very challenging
to be able to recover
from something that
occurs to those services
in that pipeline if you don't have,
don't cover the entire pipeline all
at once like Clumio does.
That's what we recommend
as the first requirement
for architecting for
resiliency in the AI world
that we live in today.
The second is speed.
Sharon expects fast responses
from that smartphone app.
AWS has been around for a long time
and they've done a great
job at raising that bar
to make sure that customers have speed
in what they're doing in the AWS cloud.
Clumio recognizes that and so
we have built an architecture
that is built for that,
so that you can have
a good user experience
as often as you possibly can.
Lastly, scale.
We recognize that our app was very small.
The watch lists were only
about 20 DynamoDB entries.
We had about 5,000 or so S3 objects.
We only had one S3 table.
We only had one S3 vector.
It's odds are your magnitudes
order larger than that.
So Clumio has built their
product and their application
and their solution along with Commvault
to keep pace with that scale.
We know that it's dynamically
changing every single day.
We know that you're adding and
subtracting every single day.
You need a solution to
increase that resiliency
and maintain that
resiliency that will scale.
Those are our three
recommendations for architecting,
for best practices for the gen AI world
that we live in today.
But more generally speaking, we also,
Clumio is a eight plus year old company.
We've come to know what best
practices mean for the cloud.
So we wanna provide you with some guidance
in three different particular areas today
before we leave you.
The first is recovery in place matters.
Not having to go to
the work and the effort
to reconfigure your app after
you only recover partially
will slow things down and
make your resiliency suffer.
We wanna accelerate that
availability of that data
so that sharing has minimal interruption
or your businesses have
minimal interruption.
The second is, like I
mentioned a second ago,
the cloud is dynamic.
I've been working on it
for about six years now.
I was at AWS.
I observed it firsthand.
It changes every single day.
It shrinks, it grows.
So we wanna be able to
help you with discovering
what already exists now,
but also what has not been yet created.
We have a part of the
product called Discover
that will help automate
that level of protection.
And then lastly, like I keep
saying, scale is huge in AWS.
I don't see that slowing down.
If anything, that'll accelerate
in the next 15, 20 years
plus that AWS exists.
So you need a product that will be elastic
and scale with you.
Clumio is a 100% serverless architecture
that is built for scale.
So that is our third best practice
that we wanna provide with you today.
I really enjoyed speaking with all of you
on behalf of Akshay and myself.
We don't want this conversation to end.
We want it to continue, even
when you walk out those doors.
So we wanna offer a few other things
that we're doing before
re:Invent ends this week.
The first is an AWS game day
that starts at one o'clock tomorrow.
It's gonna be a little bit of fun.
It's gonna be a little bit of sci-fi.
We're calling it Race to Recover,
but it's based on a zombie
apocalypse or app-ocalypse
is I guess how we're pronouncing
it on the screen there.
You can see the QR code.
I'll be there if you wanna
talk to me more there
or after the session.
I'm available 100%.
I'll be there, like I said,
at one o'clock tomorrow.
And then right after game day,
we're gonna do a happy
hour just before replay
just so that you can have some relaxation
and comfort and enjoyment
before going having
some fun at the concert.
That's all for me today.
I really enjoyed speaking with you.
Like I said, I'm gonna go ahead
and turn it back over
to Akshay to wrap us up.
- Thank you, Jeff.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
If you wanna learn more about everything
that we talked about,
number one, you can
sign up for a free trial
on AWS Marketplace.
It's really simple.
It's a 14-day free trial.
And then if you wanna learn more
about Clumio Backtrack for DynamoDB,
you can scan the QR
code to access the blog.
And then if you wanna learn more
about Clumio for Apache Iceberg,
you can use the third QR code here,
and it's gonna tell you all
that you need to know about it.
Thank you so much for
attending our session
and have a wonderful day.
And Jeff and I will be
here for a few more minutes
to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)